Sir.
I'll give it up
for dark brandy.
And then I'm happy to be here.
Real quick, Mr.
President,
you left some of your
classified documents that you get to be
getting there.
Don't give them to them.
I put them in a safe place.
You don't know where to keep them. I'm
happy to be here, though.
Happy to be here.
Very happy.
Very happy to be here.
So it's a pleasure to be here.
Among our country's greatest leaders,
distinguished media organizations,
both property brothers and Dr.
Fauci,
if you see Fouchier,
take a picture with him
that show a new booster shot
which I'll look good, though.
I've been I've been watching
and looking around all night.
You'll look good.
You dress nice,
you got the nice threads on.
You got the jewelry glistening
like everybody
got a little piece
of the settlement money from Fox News
and that's all I have to say about that
because I'm not going
to have dominion on my ass.
I loved in the matter of that.
Let me just say right now,
my favorite voting machine is
Dominion voting machines.
When I go to the polls, I
make sure it is a Dominion machine
that I use.
If your election need the truth,
put dominion in your booth
that's
going to do so.
There's three people
you don't want to see in a courtroom.
That's Dominion
Cardi B or Gwyneth Paltrow.
You don't lose
I like to
thank Tamara Keith
and the White House
Correspondents Association for having me.
Thank you for that.
I'm well aware
that not everybody in
this room knows who I am.
So let's just address
the elephant in the room.
I know what it is.
Half this room think I'm Kenan Thompson.
Other half
think I'm Louis Armstrong.
President Biden thinks I'm going to daddy
golf.
Family matters
nonetheless,
I'm happy to be here at this event.
Among government officials
who speak to MSNBC, former government
officials who now work at MSNBC
and future government officials
who currently work at MSNBC,
an often overlooked
purpose of tonight's dinner.
You know, serious business.
The overlooked purpose of tonight's
dinner is to award scholarships
to students
who have shown great achievements
in journalism.
That's right.
These brave
young souls
are the future of the industry.
And I'd like to stop right now
and congratulate tonight's
top scholarship recipient,
Arizona State singer Jorge Santos.
Oh, yeah.
George couldn't be here tonight.
He's auditioning for RuPaul's Drag Race.
It's not bad.
And we say good luck to you, George.
Sashay away.
And also, speaking of drag queens.
Tell. Can we stop?
What?
The groom and stuff
can you stop talking about
the drag queens are not at a school
to groom your kids.
Stop it.
And even if they were, most of them kids
gonna get shot at school.
Ain't no problem.
Don't grow on pass
legislation.
Like they booze don't bother me.
I'm like, oh, my, Mitch McConnell.
I ain't got no soul
It's a tumultuous time
in the media, though.
We've got layoffs everywhere.
BuzzFeed News, NPR, Axios Washington
Post, ESPN.
Paramount Global
right now
is considering offers
from Byron
Allen and Tyler Perry to purchase B.E.T.
That's how bad it is out there.
These companies are so broke,
they're giving it back to black people
which by the way, it's
not what we meant
when we say
black people want to reparations.
We make cash and give it to us.
And Harriet Tubman to win is
but tonight,
we are all unified on the one thing.
And that scandal
has scandals.
Scandals have been devouring careers
this year, the untouchable.
Tucker Carlson is out of a job
now.
Some people celebrate it.
But to Tucker's staff, I want you to know
that I know what you're feeling.
I work at The Daily Show.
So I, too, have been blindsided
by the sudden departure
of the host of the fake news program
Tough to get caught up.
Got caught up like that
due from Vanderpump Rules.
Text message
said,
I don't know what Vanderpump
Rules is about.
I'm just watching a couple of times.
My friends told me
it's like being left before. Like people
was in session.
No succession is power for white people.
No.
Tucker Carlson is power for white people.
No, that's white power.
You know it. Never mind.
Don't worry about doubling up about that.
We got to get Tucker back on the air, Mr.
President, because right now
there's millions of Americans
that don't even know why they hate you.
Fox claimed Dominion conspired
with the Democrats to rig the election.
And the Democrats
should be flattered that they thought
that y'all was smart enough
to rig an election
one that needed a run off
to beat a werewolf
But it's not over for you.
Fox News is still that bad.
More bad news coming down the pipe.
That Smartmatic voting machine
lawsuit is coming.
That's right.
Smartmatic is coming for you
and they want more money than me.
Let me just say right now,
my favorite voting machine
is the smart matic voting machine.
And your election is the truth.
Put Smartmatic in your booth
But I think it's fair
that we should give credit
where credit is due.
Tucker Carlson is the first host
to get fired from Fox News for something
that's only
partially about how he treats women.
That's progress.
He shattered the asshole ceiling
Speaking of assholes,
Don Lemon is out of a job
Don Lemon,
my dog, Don Lemon.
Don Lemon
released a statement
saying he got fired from CNN.
Then CNN released a statement
saying that they offered Don a meeting.
They had to part ways because Don
Lemon can't
even accurately report a story
about Don Lemon
I still think that Don deserve more CNN.
Anyhow, you fired somebody.
That's messed up.
How funny is it
that you work in the news,
then watch on the news that
you got fired from the news.
Don Lemon
is now the most obnoxious guy
in the history of CNN. That's not fair.
Even Jeffrey
Toobin looking at Don Lemon like who?
He wrote me the wrong place
let him down, go was the wrong move.
You shouldn't have let him go,
not just on CNN.
First off,
Don was firing
when y'all was letting them drink.
You shouldn't have cut off his liquor.
You don't fire
your host
after the first couple of scandals.
Let the stand.
The scandals got to stack up.
You got to get you got to get ratings.
Yes. Don Lemon was a diva.
And he said a couple of
women are ragged in the face,
but that's a promotion at Fox News.
But I ultimately understand
why CNN did what they did.
I get it.
It's about morals.
Should be no place on air
for someone
who speaks with wild disregard.
It doesn't consider the blowback
to their coworkers or their company.
Thankfully, CNN has taken
steps in the right direction.
We got rid of Don Lemon
and they've now given a show
to Charles Barkley
to Charles Barkley's cohost, Gayle King.
We say good luck.
I think it's going to be a good show.
The whole show is going to be
Charles Barkley. Saying something crazy.
Then Gayle King looking into the camera.
Charles
scandals.
I spoke in Texas
about so many scandals,
the king of scandals,
President Donald Trump.
Just for a moment,
can we just all acknowledge,
can we just all be honest
and just say that the Trump
risk didn't
hit like we thought it was going to hit?
We're so desensitized to scandals
now that Trump
didn't do what
I thought it was going to do.
The trap for us
is like a pot
brownie you ate 4 hours ago.
You are Do I feel justice?
This don't feel like justice.
Let me try one of them.
Georgia arraignment brown.
It's maybe that a hint
of the I that's asked to
taint followed Trump scandals.
There's too many Trump scandals
to keep up with
keeping up with Trump scandals.
It's like watching Star Wars movies.
You got to watch the third one
to understand in the first one.
Then you got to
you can't miss the second one
because it's got Easter eggs
for the thick one.
Donald Trump
is the only politician
who scandals got spinoffs on Disney.
Plus
but the Trump arrests,
it made everybody question
what they believe.
You thought you lean one way politically.
Then Trump got locked up.
Everybody started waffling.
Put Republicans
between a rock and a hard place.
Donald Trump that locked up for years.
All Republican.
I've been saying for years
we got to get tough on crime.
Trump got arrested.
We met black crime
Same thing with the liberals.
Two liberals was all confused after Trump
got arrested.
We got to abolish President
Trump, got arrested, bring back reckless
I don't know about you all, but for me,
the easiest scandal to follow
was the Trump documents scandal.
That was the one that was easy to follow.
Simple is some stuff
that's supposed to be in the White House
that ain't
in the media.
Y'all did Charles job.
Donald jumped on that story.
As soon as the Trump documents
story broke,
everybody was down at Mar a Lago.
Reporting live from the documents.
Everyone else I know.
And then we found out
Joe Biden had documents, too.
And it was like it's not a big deal.
It's not a big deal.
Everybody got documents.
Everybody got back with Mike Pence
at some back room.
Oh, look, the Chinese by balloon.
Would you look at that?
Oh,
well done, media.
Happy to be here.
Very happy to be here.
If there's one person
that could use the scandal,
it's Ron DeSantis
that boys is just running around.
Just pass
every controversial law he can think of.
Think in Mexico, activate voters.
That's not how you activate voters
in this country.
Run. Everybody know how to do politics.
This is America. We don't pass laws.
You make a promise to voters,
and then you don't do it.
That's what
the great leaders
in this room understand.
You know how to make things not happen.
The only thing
the only thing Ron DeSantis has done
that I got to give him credit for
this boy.
He got people riled up.
All the stuff they can't understand.
Don't nobody.
They don't know what
critical race theory is.
Get these people riled up about something
that they can't even define, like crypto
or NFT is
as any Republican.
This anti CRT
ask in a Republican
trying to explain CRT,
they sound like a Democrat
trying to explain the charges
against Trump.
Is bad everywhere.
He's got to stop it.
We've got to stop it. We got the files.
We got files. We'll be right back.
I'm Rachel Maddow.
I have files
with Rachel Maddow.
Get them files on you.
Just wrap
i think Republicans
will be surprised, man,
if y'all would just be real
about what CRT is that?
You can be surprised.
Some black folks
might might meet you halfway,
but you got to tell the truth.
You can't.
A lot of black people call it what it is.
Anti CRT policies are an attack
on black history
and an attempt to erase the contributions
of black people from the history books.
That's what it is.
You are trying to erase black people
and a lot of black people
wouldn't mind some of that erasure
as long as that
black person is Clarence Thomas.
A
billionaire named Harlan Crow
flying Clarence Thomas all over the world
on unreported trips
like the Instagram model, taking plants
to the Maldives
and the beaches are not paid for us.
Mama's House.
This billionaire paid
for Clarence Thomas.
Parker's house.
I got to
I got to give it up to billionaires.
Billionaires, boy,
y'all, y'all are relentless.
Yo, y'all always come up with something
new to buy.
Like, just when you think of everything
you could buy on Earth from billionaires
will come up with a new thing.
Y'all bad space rockets.
You bought Twitter.
This man bought
a Supreme Court justice
do you understand how rich you have to be
to buy a Supreme Court a black one?
On top of that,
there's only two in stock
and Haaland Crow
owns half the inventory
we can all see Clarence Thomas,
but he belongs to billionaire
Harlan Crow.
And that's what an NFT is
Everybody's got some scandalous stuff.
Despite the challenging times we live
in, I look around this room
and I see people that are hardworking.
Many of you.
I don't even think
you should be working that hard.
We should be inspired by the events
in France.
They rioted
when the retirement age went up two years
to 64.
They rioted
because they didn't want to work till 64.
Meanwhile, in America,
we have an 80 year old man
begging us for four more years of work
begging,
begging
let me finish the job.
That's not a campaign slogan.
That's a plea
limitation.
No finisher
I do.
I do wish you the best of luck
on the campaign trail, Mr.
President.
You got a lot of things
that you're going to have to navigate
a lot of hurdles.
You've had quite a few scandals.
You know, we
I know we know about the documents,
we know about the laptops,
but there's been no scandal
more damaging than the scandal.
Love is Joe Biden.
The weight
say what you want about our president.
Look,
when you wake up from that nap,
work gets done,
you might doze off,
but the infrastructure bill
oh, student loan forgiveness.
Hey, do we free Brittney Griner?
Free Brittney Griner?
But I think the most insulting scandal
to fall
to the feet of the Biden administration
was place at the feet of
our Madam Vice President.
The scandal of
what does Camilla do
which is a disrespectful question.
That's a disrespectful question
because nobody ever asked that question
of the vice president
until a woman got the job
I'm going to ask
I don't know what Mike Pence did.
The only thing I know about Mike Pence
is that he's really good
at playing hide and seek at the Capitol
you got to be crafty to catch Mike Pence.
And that kept
hitting the wall of nooks and crannies
Don't put the camera on her
and the Mike Pence joke.
Don't do that.
Nobody said they tried to set you up.
Madam Vice President, the
at the end of the day,
as a vice president,
the only thing you got to do is just be
better than Dick Cheney.
That's the bar.
Just be better than Dick Cheney.
They made a documentary
about Dick Cheney.
Now, I don't know
much about the job of vice president,
but I do know
if they can make a documentary
about your time as vice president,
you vice president.
It incorrectly
and if a VP whose job is really
just waiting
to step in to save the country
in case of emergency,
then the job of vice president
is a perfect job for a black woman,
shouldn't be, but it is.
And whatever you do accomplish,
whatever you do accomplish,
are you going to do it?
Just give a man credit for anything.
You do all the immigration stuff.
You two knocked out
and got all this banking
and you got the Internet down there
taking care of all this postpartum stuff.
They just don't give a man credit
for what you done.
By the way, Mr.
President, great job at being the first
woman vice president
of color.
I don't even know how you did that part
Wonderful job.
Happy to be here.
But tonight
tonight is all about you,
all the journalists,
the defenders of free speech,
the people who show truth to the world
through different mediums,
through television,
through print, through radio,
through whatever. China.
Let us see you on Tic-Tacs.
But the industry
that covers all of these scandals
isn't immune to them.
They're self
the issue with good media is that
most people can't afford that.
All the essential, fair
and nuanced reporting,
it's all stuck behind a paywall
people can't afford rent.
People can't afford food,
not healthy food.
They can't afford an education.
They damn sure can afford to pay
for the truth.
Things you want
about a conspiracy theory, but
at least is affordable
unless you
Alex Jones, it goes
you by not having to make
and I understand that
we have to put the stuff
behind the paywall
because creating the truth is important.
People can't afford the truth,
but you all can afford to go find
the truth. For free.
The work you do as
journalists is important.
It's essential.
It's dangerous.
My father was an embedded
reporter on the frontlines
with black platoons in Vietnam.
He was in the South African Soweto riots.
He covered that
the civil war in Rhodesia,
which we know today is Zimbabwe.
And my father came back home
and co-founded the National Black Network
because he wanted to tell black stories
to American Urban
Radio Networks
now, and they've been doing it
for 50 years.
And that's part of what my father
wanted to do. You know,
and I know it was
hard because, you know, black
dad is love telling you
when something was difficult,
like was shooting at me.
Boy,
I would never dropped my tape recorder
my daddy tell war stories
like Brian Williams
and
Lester Holt didn't laugh at that one.
Okay so I next
the journalism course.
That's the truth of the matter.
The journalism cost to people,
but it also cost the journalists.
It could even cost you your freedom.
We talked about
even though The Wall Street
Journal sitting in a Russian prison
as we speak on espionage charges,
which espionage charges, by the way,
that's the foreign equivalent
of saying someone fits the description,
Evan.
And hundreds of journalists
imprisoned all over the world
simply for doing their job.
We got to defend brave journalists
most national stories in this country
at some point were first a local story
and
those stories
and championed by reporters at outlets
that many of them have now folded.
If we can't figure out a way
to pay local reporters,
then as a country
we're only left with that
many more blind spots
to where the ball is happening.
You hear about all these newsrooms
getting cut, says
every article
that Tamra's
been sending me in
the last two months is just
the newsroom is getting cut, cut.
And people
were cutting budgets,
but you never hear about the multimillion
dollar executives
reducing their salaries
within these organizations.
Now, how do we fix this
I don't know.
I'm a comedian.
I was just up in
It's not my job to have the solution
that's we got.
But local local reporting
is very important.
My mother is here tonight
and
I know she's furious right now
because I'm trying to put on camera.
But my mother was among
a group of black student protesters
fighting for equality in the sixties.
At Delta State University and
and
that was a dangerous time.
But those types of incidents
were covered by local reporters.
And some of the shame
that came
from the national embarrassment
of treating people inhumanely.
It's part of the pressure
that helped to create
that type of change.
What would have become of my mother
and those of the protesters
of a local journalist
wasn't there telling the story
and now is no different.
But thankfully,
my mother's story was told
she got to complete a degree
at Delta State
and continued on the Florida
A&M and got another degree.
And then for the last 45 years
has worked
at a historically black
colleges and educator
and administrator and
one of those many black colleges.
They need a little bit more funding.
You've got a 20 on your job
here to send that down
to one of the black colleges
to my mom I say thank you
for everything you've done for me
and for helping countless student
in Birmingham have the opportunity
to see a college degree
and to see an opportunity to grow.
You know,
my mother's journey
may not have even begun
if not for brave journalists
who chose to chronicle
history in real time.
And I don't know how to ever repay my mom
for what she's done for me
and what she's done for so many people.
In Alabama.
But just know, Mama, if
if a white billionaire call
you an offer to buy
your house, please sell it
because I might want to become an NFT.
Thank you so much.
So the Correspondents Association,
thank you so much for Tamara Keith.
Thank you all so much. Good night.